[Musique]
et on commence avec vous Gabriel Gontier
donc je le disais tout à l'heure dans
les titres mardi dernier un goûté de fin
d'année dans le collège à équeeville a
viré la catastrophe oui tout à fait
Régine un élève de 3e a versé du
détergent mélangé à une boisson sucrée à
sa professeur d'art plastique
l'enseignante du collège Léonard de
Vinci s'est rapidement senti mal
hospitalisée elle est sortie mercredi de
l'hôpital et à pris les cours ce matin
elle a déposé plainte contre l'élève à
l'origine de l'empoisonnement un élève
avec qui elle avait eu une altercation
le jour de l'incident une enquête a été
ouverte et le jeune homme a avoué dans
la matinée ce qui l'a qualifié être une
mauvaise blague Julien Leroi s'est rendu
auprès des collégiens de l'établissement
on écoute leur réaction c'est pas bien
de faire ça à une prof qui qui nous
enseigne des trucs qui veut nous aider à
progresser dans la vie de tous les jours
je pense que c'est pas bien et aussi il
y a en ce moment en France il y a ça
arrive à beaucoup de professeurs des
agressions comme ça et en ce moment
c'est pas normal queer ça tout ça tout
ça c'est choquant un peu et en plus la
prof elle était pas méchante ou quoi
donc elle était là depuis 2 ans ça fait
2 ans qu'on est ici nous donc on la
connaît en vrai elle était pas méchante
enfin elle elle était strict quand il
fallait mais elle était pas méchante
quoi et nous avons appris en fin
d'après-midi que deux collégiens ont été
placés en garde à vue pour tentative
d'empoisonnement et complicité et la
région île-de-fance aide les villes
particulièrement à toucher par les
émeutes de cet été dans les ivelines oui
six communes ivelinoises vont bénéficier
d'une enveloppe pour faire face au
dégâts engendrés par les émeutes de
l'été l'été dernier à la suite de la
mort de Naël les villes de mant-el jolie
la verrière poissie chanteloulévin
Fontenis lefleuri ou encore Sartrouville
avait subi des dégradations importantes
une enveloppe globale d'1,6 million
d'euros va être envoyé par la région
cette somme ne correspond pas à une
subvention pure mais à des avances
remboursables selon nos confrères de
cette su actctu et pour anticiper
sereinement les départs pour les
vacances de fin d'année vous nous faites
un point bisonfuté oui car le trafic
s'annonce difficile pour vos départs en
vacances bisonfuté voir rouge dans le
sens des départs pour les journées de
vendredi et samedi il est conseillé de
partir avant 10h en évitant l'autoroute
à 10 le vendredi si vous prenez la route
samedi mieux vaut se déplacer avant 6h
du matin et contourner l'autoroute à 13
pour le réveillant les départs s'annonce
plutôt calme enfin dimanche bisonfuté
annonce vert dans le sens des retours et
bien merci Gabrielle pour ses conseils
et toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous êtes
témoins d'une information qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous le partager en le mettant sur les
hashtag 78 news sur les réseaux sociaux